[Music]
last time you're on the show you were
talking about your your ninja skills and
you and you use swords you showed us
your skill with ninja sighs yeah I
understand that you have kicked it up a
notch
yes what are you studying now well I
have invented a new game called ninja
darts which is like darts but with ninja
stars ninja stars ninja stars I've only
seen them in movies those are the
circular sharp discs that you throw when
it goes right into a guy's forehead
ideally yes right yeah well with
practice you can get there okay so so
yeah so I think we're gonna play some
ninja and you're you're good at this
you're actually I'm not a pro but it
sure is fun all right I just wanted to
see this we're gonna play some ninja
darts here for a second let's cross over
try this right now would you show us
absolutely I want to see how it works
okay
look at that killer look at his face
everybody is it the menacing looks kind
like Andy okay so it looks like the most
inept killer in the world so that's a
killer who said I've got these two guys
oh no they have ninja stars
it's an arat killer all right show us
what we do okay so there's really no
rules except if you hit something you
win pretty much okay all right so we can
we can start how you hold it kind of
like a dart you you you hold I don't
know if this is the right way I just you
know I got mine off eBay so so you hold
it you don't know what you're doing at
all I don't know okay but you throw it
you have it in the center there and you
just kind of throw okay that's right
yeah but I knocked him out yeah okay I'm
not gonna try this before so everyone
yeah yes to it once so these souls
members are hurting now I'm just tossing
them was not even thinking any everybody
to throw them all right watch this this
one he's still alive he's coming for me
I'll save you Chris
[Applause]
we're gonna go to commercial but you got
to try one of these really fast here
I'll this is my prize when I don't want
to touch that right here and II just
start chucking them alright alright try
one Andy imagine he's someone you know
[Applause]
questo for laser be right back